a handy if I hope you know who's who at
this point they
pro right noite hopes I'm yeah
last eight years ago as I saw this
interesting article that
and he is the in the United States use a
Gallup poll
history in 10 21 10 the
and yes leaking a draft Cisco California
San Luis Obispo yet Naples Florida Ann
Arbor Mich
in San Jose Calif ha huang et
Fort Collins Colorado never to you
boulder
colorado is to cart is right there that
my me
and number one Los Angeles sorry sister
is
row you Utah
yeah really we'll run you up but
you thought very confusing but I'm not
you before we get to your child back
go I she waited to stop
surely what makes us happy you know I
was the last
whereas I'll weather-related people that
you're around the tapes
jobs you know like New York and Los
Angeles where everyone you know those
things you like
go-getter see right not on the list
that's insane
well it's because your LA you're
constantly stressed out about me
money cost living is way too high right
student
him so I think that's part of the
problem but I have to say
LA is the place he has I love that
right and environment where there's
competition and
you know the their endless possibilities
your career
up sometimes you know just your their
last
be work to live not live to work
yeah and for me the other way around up
you want the CS
ice la siesta I love feeling like
yeah working harder schools purposely
that's what really
me happy but another thing that makes me
happy is good
Julia good letter hot men
Latin men like you're not going to find
your I'm
know that year elegant compared Europe I
okay here Pro Bowler bowl there you're
really LA or Europe
blue state so I i'm aware. Spain okay
yeah and she's going to Spain mother
happy
area watch out use you I'll
the yet will the new york you know I
grew up suffers a
your city and lead in your city
basically less like forty years which
year ago and there's actually no
comparison between
your his there's so much everything and
you almost don't realize it would
constantly
hustle and bustle in the the and like
everyone should
miserable and angry but then when you
get actually talk to people they're
actually quite
the your yeah I know you want to know
we're always happy
directions usually yeah way by month but
will at least you know they'll get
somewhere up LA
it to me the York like is the mostly
his honor you know that's not ash but I
do it actually true true religion
perhaps I'll or many other yeah but for
me this is the perfect plaintively
lifestyle and that were is always
happening here in
make this its you armored right here
birds he yeah well yours
loser animal there's no place like New
York so
LA's definitely back Pearson LA's
perfect next laid-back hard-working ugly
grace I'd love to see I can't imagine
living anywhere else
the office you lower were clearly show
deporting let
where where baths they were here by I
have been to Portland
yet yen really really want to go there I
am but we should talk to me these are
the things we're showing our new york
and Ellie Beiser profile use all the
help we got approved
biaz you slater's endeavored pro
it is a place yeah it is a place I'm
what's so great about
I don't know if you're a pro it up lease
lessons I
Honolulu that seems pretty obvious yet
then you got lights and was anything
this
is BOJ outgoing Eagles articles and I
their
leading breast breast have not been
sleeping at last
you are interested san Francisco's
number or greater ask
in the area shared this is number nine
which his head
everyone says it's a great city I they
release
breezy credit it is very says
I love sepsis last time I went my friend
Lauren
we have so much fun didn't rent-a-car
just let water out
you walk through out the hires yeah so
great
so many cool areas up the Mission
District is my favorite
house be recent s be freezer
2.4 to doctor yeah I and we were really
curious what you think where you guys
live what makes you want to leave their
this weather over right job this having
family close alright
thing I already had a good week family
whatever it is less
no comments right down below and we make
the trip to grow
I know you create the do
done